thank you very much Hannah thanks to all
of you for coming here this evening and
what could actually be more Russian than
sitting in the Royal Borough of
Kensington and Chelsea to discuss
Vladimir Putin what says Russia more
than that and as you will know put in a
hugely polarizing figure some hated
thinking of the cases of [ __ ] Riot in
their imprisonment or McCord ocassi some
revere him and love him look at those
big majorities he racks up whenever
there is opinion polling taken in the
country and some or rather all would
agree that whether you love him or hate
him he is of huge significance and look
no further if you're as we're seeing as
we are in the Royal Geographical
society's spin the globe and land on for
example Syria where Russia is playing a
huge and significant role perhaps some
of which we may even touch on this
evening so a polarizing figure on the
world stage but undoubtedly a hugely
important one and to discuss him and the
question before us which I'll remind you
is Putin has been good for Russia a for
people who wrestle with that question
some almost literally full time and do
that in a very expert way I'm going to
introduce them all one by one as they
participate in art and in our debate to
make their opening speeches I'm going to
just say one thing about the format
tonight you will have already as you
know voted on your way in to give us
some sense of the mood of the room if
you like and I'll be giving the results
of that indicative opening ballot after
we've heard the opening speeches from
the panel up here and then later on
after you've heard from them and after
we've had a chance to debate with all of
you opening the debate to the floor you
will then have one of these which I hope
you already have with you it's pretty
self-explanatory if you vote for
want to tear off a little bit that says
four and slip that into the ballot box
if it's against against and then if you
still haven't made up your mind despite
the scintillating and pointed speeches
up here put the whole thing in the
ballot box and that will count as an
abstention the format is a traditional
debate where we will have two speakers
for the motion to against they are
confined to ten to twelve minutes each
no more if you hear me
pinging the glass it isn't sheer
rudeness on my part it is a pre-agreed
system in which I'm reminding them to
wind up so that's how we're going to do
it and it's get underway with our first
speaker for the motion making the case
for the view that Vladimir Putin has
been good for Russia he is the managing
director of the independent investment
research firm trusted sources he's lived
in Russia for many years and was a
former diplomat in the British Embassy
in Moscow our first speaker for the
motion
Christopher Granville
thank you very much Jonathan for that
introduction thank you ladies and
gentlemen for coming out in such force
to contemplate this rather hangdog
portraits of and the first thing I
should say is that for me a distinct
feeling of once more unto the breach
because I spoke in an intelligence
squared debate on the same side of a
similar motion nine years ago and that
just goes to show what a venerable and
successful institution intelligence word
has become well done them and my
opponents or one of the lead opponents
on that occasion was a gentleman called
buddy sandwich which is Oscar and I
don't wish to tarnish our opponents this
evening with that Association especially
as it might boomerang against me because
if we are to believe what we are told
about his letter to ladina putin shortly
before he apparently committed suicide
recently he wanted to apologize for the
damage he'd done and perhaps he'd be on
our side of the debate which is not an
association which I personally would
favor but anyway let's move on it's very
flattering to be invited back repeat
business is one of life's more reliable
satisfactions and especially I imagine
for politicians especially when they get
repeatedly reelected by the free vote of
their citizens as has been the case of
course with the subject of our
discussion this evening
Putin lady Nevada Mirage and the effect
that he's had on Russia now I address
the battlecry once more unto the breach
not only to myself but also to you dear
friends many of you I see of veterans of
that previous event all those years ago
and I just found out in the green room
from my comrade-in-arms this evening
Boris Jordan that he too was in the
audience on that occasion in 2004
welcome to the platform Boris let's do
battle together our goal and decided the
motion is to build on the gratifying
success we had that time around but I
fear it won't be easy and I don't wish
to sound like one of those players
coming out on the court starting to make
excuses before the
game has started but years have flown
under this under the bridge have flowed
stuff happens it has this habit of
happening and just by way of comparison
imagine if we were discussing this
evening someone who has been in the
minds of everyone in this country
Margaret Thatcher in the last years of
her power it would have been tough much
easier once time was passed and people
can think back and look that's the
medicine which she administered as
distasteful whatever one thinks of her
personally as well but beneficial but in
the last years of her power she fell
victim to hubris and the illusion of
indispensability the classic pitfalls of
a successful politician and to lay my
cards out straight from the beginning I
see Vladimir Putin as quite an ordinary
successful politician F anyway that's
our problem on this side of the motion
and you rightly expect us to grapple
with that problem but I do have another
worry ladies and gentlemen which I think
concerns all of us on either side of the
debate and all of you and this is that
we risk in this discussion this evening
lapsing into a kind of scorecard
exercise two parallel discussions what
was the good what has been the good
stuff that's happened in Russia since
their dinner Putin came to power what
about the bad stuff how are we going to
weight it one against the other and then
the parallel discussion well here we
have to introduce the c-word of our
debate this evening counter factual the
good stuff how did how should mr. Putin
share the credit for the good stuff and
the blame for the bad stuff or vice
versa
so either as we are bound to argue he
deserves credit for so much as what has
happened especially the huge increase in
living standards the reduction in
poverty not only in relation to the
disastrous 1990s but also to the Soviet
period and as a result of which Russian
people are richer and freer than they
have ever been in history and I
challenge our opponents to
reject that contention including the bit
and freer and of course we would also
want to argue that for all the very ugly
things that persist that the blame
should not be entirely or mainly taken
by Putin but should be attributed rather
to the poisonous legacy of the Soviet
past and also the legacy of the
aftermath of the collapse of 1991 when
as Alexander Solzhenitsyn said in the
Russia question from under the rubble
and ruins of the depraved system emerged
such monsters in such plunder as has
never been seen in history
so that's of course our counterfactual
and our esteemed opponents will argue
well I won't do their job for them but
you get the idea
vice versa and so now I've even been
thinking we should have a matrix where
you'd have one access which is good
things and bad stuff good at the top and
at the bottom the horizontal axis is
Putin credit reporting to blame on the
right then the bottom left quadrant if
you get more dots in there then we're
gonna win my brain is hurting already
and I had the advantage of popping out
of the office this morning to cafe
narrow for half an hour try and think
about all of this but the trouble is
that I wonder if this is going to get us
very far ding-dong Oh for and against
don't get me wrong I'm quite happy to
spa in this boxing ring the reason is
because of the gothic horror consensus
about Russia that comes especially from
so much international media coverage
allow such ample scope for factual
correction and perspectives that many of
you might quite respectably respectively
have missed and I and I am a saying that
I include the genuine horrors one can
list them my list is topped by Beslan
pretty obvious where all those children
died in after the terrorist attack in
North Ossetia the nor dost theater the
murder to come closer to London of
Alexander Litvinenko
the death in pretrial detention has said
gain Magnitsky now
Jonathan you mentioned the feisty girls
who went to prison for their song and I
don't think they I think it's an insult
to those other victims to even have them
in the same company but there we are
they'd been mentioned my benchmark would
be as Dmitry Medvedev said that their
pre pretrial detention was quite enough
punishment my benchmark being Otis Ferry
being banged up here for four months for
raiding the House of Commons as you may
recall anyway but the let's let's just
if we want to spar in this boxing ring
so we can all start the good stuff I
mentioned already
now our opponents will surely say it's
all due to the old price and but for
Putin that oil windfall would have been
used better for the good of the people
and there will be less corruption well
that's a claim which may sound plausible
to some of you especially if you assign
lis predisposed to regard the gentleman
with distaste but no let's look at some
facts and some decisions which Putin has
taken of his own discretion
in response to this manner not down from
heaven but up from the subsoil of
Western Siberia well one could mention
first and foremost I think the decision
not to fritter it away to set up the oil
Stabilization Fund which meant that when
an external shock came which it must be
given the nature of this economy which
is not his fault or anyone else's fault
the people were sheltered and unlike in
1998 when there was a 30% cut in living
standards for the whole country after
that shock in 2008 the population were
largely protected as were real incomes
now counterfactual let's look for one ah
I thought of one Gordon Brown did he
wisely and judiciously save all that tax
revenue from our oil sector here in the
UK which is the financial services
sector to help us in the downturn oh
look we didn't know spent it all and he
he then went he then went of course we
have GDP in UK just now recovering to
where it used to be in 2007 whereas
Russia two years ago demography Putin
has used the money for supporting in the
birth rate
and for mothers having babies pensions
pensioners must not live in poverty
raise the pension above the subsistence
level so we could go on and on but in my
last couple of minutes which John's a
new signal to me I want to do something
more ambitious I may burn up in the
process but here goes getting out of the
dingdong what should I think this really
counts is has the price of this
stability which is a loud growth being
too high is the country moving forward
is it stagnant disability which is so
important stability is important but is
it stagnant or is it dynamic for for the
Russian history buffs among you is it
Alexander the third or Brezhnev well I
say it's dynamic because the we are not
in a Soviet dead end we can see that a
middle class has formed Vladimir Putin
himself said when asked about the
protesters in Moscow last year what do
you think he said when I look at these
people I think and I'm told that this is
the result of the Putin regime and he
used those words ironically then I am
proud that is the way forward living
standards and a middle class must come
first then you can have political
competition and more accountability and
less corruption this is not a dead end
in the Soviet Union what we see in
proteins Russia even in the present
relatively late period of entropy is
that there is a path forward and it's
that point which I would hope would be
your basis for voting in favor of the
motion thank you very much thank you
thank you very much just one very quick
follow-up you said he was struck you as
an ordinary successful politician and
I'm just thinking I was trying hard to
think of one an example of an ordinary
successful politician who had been
president for years
step back and was Prime Minister before
he's then came back as president after
that it doesn't seem that ordinary to me
from one job to another job and then
back again into the into the top job out
again and back in again okay well I
don't I think this will be a first at
parallel to been drawn between that's
terrific thank you and there'll be more
more we'll hear more from Christopher
Granville later on our next speaker
against the motion against the motion
that Putin has been good for Russia is a
Russian journalist based in Moscow the
author of the man without a face the
unlikely rise of Vladimir Putin she was
sacked as editor of a nature magazine
for refusing to cover president Putin's
hang glider flight with Siberian cranes
she's the former director of radio
liberties Russian service working on two
books currently one on [ __ ] ride
another one on the Boston bombing our
next speaker against the motion Masha
Gessen
thank you I think I should say it's
especially gratifying to be at the Royal
Geographic Society after losing my job
to the Russian Geographic Society which
is chaired by Vladimir Putin they gave
him a particular pleasure to check in on
Facebook so responding to my opponent
well it certainly if you if you see that
you can't win a debate you try to
reframe it and I appreciate the effort
but I would like to go to the points
there there is the myth of Putin
bringing order to the chaos that Russia
was in the 1990s and that is the myth
that needs to be debunked first violent
crime which had been on the rise
throughout the 1990s started falling in
late 1998 and continued a steep fall
until 2001 the same happened with the
economy the economy which had been in
turmoil and had hit the financial crisis
of 1998 had started growing in late 1998
and continue growing steeply regardless
of Putin's coming to power the same was
happening throughout the country the
post office was working again the trains
were running on time again that sense of
order replacing chaos is something that
we often see in public opinion where
public opinion trails behind events and
so and where we see a new leader coming
in to capitalize on the gains of a
previous leadership which is exactly
what happened in Russia in 1998 at the
height of the financial crisis in Russia
the price of a barrel of Russian oil was
eight dollars the cost of getting it out
of the ground was 12 dollars that price
started growing and was growing steadily
for most of Putin's reign and that is
the beginning and end of the story now
let's look at what Putin did with that
with the oil riches now
while my opponent is correct in saying
that there was this to the ization fund
most of which has been used up there is
also the issue of paying off foreign
debt early instead of reinvesting the
money in the economy in fact
reinvestment in the economy ground to a
halt under Putin and this is what we're
seeing now we're seeing the economy
entirely dependent on oil and gas
reserves while the cost of getting those
reserves out of the ground is rising
steadily because of the lack of
reinvestment especially in anything they
make on including the national resources
industry but in addition to that look at
the look at the social sector look at
education starting next year Russian
parents are going to have two children
going to state-owned schools are going
to be to have to pay for so-called
optional subjects which is anything that
reaches beyond a couple of hours of
Russian and math each and tours of
physical education a week if you need to
get a medical test at a clinic in Moscow
you don't even have to go for our field
you have to bring your own syringe in
2013 and whereas much of that this man
you've been going is aside from being
stolen by corrupt officials which most
of it has been but a lot of it a lot of
it has been going to quiet and quell
protests and now that the economy has
slowed to a virtual standstill that
money is running out and that's where
why we're going to see whatever
approaches were going to see once the
economy slows completely is not going to
be quieted by the man called by the
money plan I think is going to be quite
violent and quite catastrophic now let's
talk about the popularity myth there's
there's several myths in the popularity
myth there's the myth of of public
opinion polls well public opinion polls
are rather problematic in Russia
the single independent public opinion
polling organization was taken over by
the state was that it in 2005 this was
one film which was headed by you really
vada was was taken over by the state
the sociologist struck out on their own
formed a non-governmental organization
which has functioned with great
difficulty but has functioned it has now
been will become one of the NGOs that
has been that have been raided and are
facing the very real prospect of closure
but also let's let's look at the numbers
that are available to us let's look at
Putin's claim that he got 63 percent in
the presidential election of March 4th
of last year well there are a couple of
independent exit polls to look at that
show that he got about 50% that may
sound like a lot but think about the
fact that he was running virtually
unopposed there were four other names on
the ballot all of those names were put
there with the with the full cooperation
and permission of the Kremlin and then
of those people campaigned so nobody who
voted for one of those four other
candidates actually was voting to see
somebody in office that was fit a 50%
protest vote that is extremely high
it is extremely high even if you don't
consider the fact that Putin has a
monopoly on the media but for the last
12 years the Kremlin has controlled all
of the state television stations and
most other media including print media
the independent media are limited to a
few newspapers and magazines one
magazine that are published in Moscow
and don't really get distributed outside
of Moscow and the internet which while
relatively free although it faces DDoS
attacks every time there's something
important is going on has the very
different aspect of you know you don't
get answers to questions you don't ask
on the Internet then having
unfettered access to social networks is
not at all the same as having access to
television and again there's no such
thing as political campaigning there's
no such thing in fact as public space
which is where we get to my opponents
claim that that only after you see the
living standards rise do you get DC
political competition but before we get
to the point about well whether we have
seen living standards rise under putin's
reign I would like to return to the
1990s again the 1990s contrary to
popular belief did see the living
standards rise by between 1991 and 1996
every Russian household acquired a new
television set between 1991 and 1996
every Russian household acquired a new
washing machine think about it think
about what a huge difference it makes to
go from having a a semi manual washing
machine which any of those who visited
Soviet bloc countries in the 1980s
should be familiar with and a fully
automatic washing machine think about
the difference that makes one when you
acquire a new television set and you see
and you did see at the time independent
media some of the best television made
in the in the world was being made in
Russia in the 1990s that the Putin
administration has been extremely
successful in propagating propagating
the myth of the wild and unruly and
horrible and scary 1990s things there
were things that were wild and unruly
and horrible and scary but it was a
system that was in the process of
writing itself and that was very very
clear by the end of the 1990s and of
course one example of that is a man that
surely all of you have heard of and
that's Mikhail Khodorkovsky his
trajectory is is very typical he's
somebody who took what he could take
without any moral qualms in the mid
1990s
who
an incredible change of heart in 1998
during the financial crisis by this time
he owned the the largest and
catastrophic lay unprofitable oil
company in Russia Yukos and as a result
of the financial crash of nineteen I did
lost the ability to pay his workers when
I had to see them and suddenly realized
for the first time in his life and the
first I think among many Russian
entrepreneurs that business had a
responsibility in addition to making
money he'd a little bit earlier than
that he and other Russian oligarchs
began to realize that if he kept taking
money and assets out of your companies
you would eventually run out of money
and assets this is something that Putin
and his cronies has to have still not
realized about Russia that if you keep
taking money and assets out of Russia
you will eventually run out of money in
assets so he unlike Putin began
reinvesting and he unlike Putin or any
of his cronies began a campaign a
concerted campaign for transparent and
good corporate governance so he was
quite successful in that he was quite
successful in creating the first Russian
company that was in many ways
living up to international standards of
corporate governor's by around 2000 year
2003 which is exactly when his
anti-corruption campaign finally landed
him in prison whereas you know he has
been for the last nine years and I
believe will be as long as radomir Putin
is in power which goes to show just how
terrified the Putin regime is of someone
who is no longer the richest man in the
world or even one of the richest men in
Russia but simply has the kind of moral
standing and [ __ ] credibility that one
can only get after spending nine years
in prison stored in his moral position
so getting back to the issue of whether
you
have whether you need a risin living
standard in order to have political
competition that sounds great a diamond
sounds right
the only problem is it has absolutely
nothing to do with Russia as it is
constituted today Russia has seen a rise
in living standards through the 90s and
certainly through the through the knots
and in 2010 although that rise in living
standard has certainly slowed and is
handicapped hugely by an enormous income
gap which is continues to grow and
incredible capital flight but Russia has
no political competition in fact what
little public space was not destroyed in
the first dozen years of putinism has
been destroyed in the last year and what
we're seeing right now in Russia is is
the final stage of the destruction of
public space we're seeing the closure of
the last of the independent media we're
seeing few protest leaders facing prison
Alexei Navalny I think will go to jail
in the next few weeks and we will see I
think 28 people get jail time this
summer between 6 & 8 years each for
participating in illegal and peaceful
protests a year ago that is not
political competition that is tyranny
thank you
thank you before we hear from our third
speaker I just want to follow up they're
central to Christopher Granville's case
was this idea that the country was
richer and freer and we heard what you
said about freedom in the country but am
i right in thinking you're not
attempting to deny that the country the
the alleviation of poverty the
Christopher Granville figure out that
that has happened under Putin that's
actually tricky because the the the
countries certainly richer but the
income gap has also grown significantly
so alleviation of poverty is a bit of a
difficult claim to make about a third of
the country continues to live below
poverty those other two thirds so you're
conceding on that point because it was
central to Christopher Campbell's case
let's go on to our third speaker he is
an American businessman of Russian
origin both his parents but also his
grandparents were Russian he is now
based in Moscow he's the president and
CEO of the wonderfully named Sputnik
group and the author of the article he
delivers that's why they like him in the
Washington Post which may end up being a
seven word summary of the argument we
get now from Boris Jordan
it's like thank you very much I am going
to try to dispense a little bit with um
a lot of the entry formalities because
of all that was just said I really want
to answer some of that but most of which
I'll answer in my formal debate I'd like
to put everyone in this room where I was
at least which I think where Marshall
was - because she was in Russia in in
1994 I moved to Russia in 1992 having
only learned about Russia through books
imagining myself riding through the snow
and the Russian fields on a troika and
imagining when I arrived Russian bells
ringing and beautiful churches and when
I got off the airplane in in 1992 was
anything but that it was very gray very
different the people did speak Russian
but they didn't speak the Russian I
learned back in the United States as a
as a descendant of firm Russian white
Emma grace and and when I want to put
you I'd like to put you into 1998 1999
and Russia unlike what Marsha says was a
very very dark place poverty was at over
40 percent inflation was at over 30
percent the country's debt to GDP was
over a hundred and ten percent the ruble
was not convertible and nobody wanted to
use it Marsha said that there was there
was an improvement in standards of
living in the 90s I can tell you there
was virtually no improvement in standard
living in 1990 as a matter of fact
almost all Russians except a very very
few lived worse in the 1990s than they
did in the 1970s and 80s
and hyperinflation destroyed the value
of their savings that they had in the
Russian government Bank it into company
debt which the level where people were
bargaining with bottles of vodka in
order to be able to feed their families
the regions were not paying any taxes to
the federal government as a matter of
fact the Urals one of the largest
regions of Russia decided
form the independent republic of Urals
and and move away from the Russian
Federation Tatarstan and many other
regions were looking at walking away
from the Federation in 1998 as the
Russian government defaulted on its
international obligations so I don't see
anything remotely what Marshall sees I
can tell you now the country was a
disaster the electoral rating of of
President Yeltsin was at a level of 3%
the country was run by oligarchs and
when I traveled internationally to raise
money for Russian companies and we were
the biggest bank in Russia raising money
for Russian companies at that time
everybody's questions to me were as
follows you know this country is not run
by a democratically elected government
it is run by an oligarchy a group of
eight or nine people that decide
everything and those eight or nine
people by the way controlled the
so-called independent media and it was
anything but independent that media all
of the major TV stations including the
so-called independent and TV and I know
a little bit about NTV because I ran it
later on were all buying media to push
their own goals forward they were not
independent they were dependent on the
money that their specific are owners
were giving them in order to project a
political image or a business interest
of theirs within the country it was not
objective in any stretch of the
imagination there was enormous global
concern about whether or not Russia
would even stay together as a nation and
there was huge issues globally and
talked about potential problems in
nuclear proliferation that is the Russia
that I remember when young President
Vladimir Putin became a young Prime
Minister Putin was elected as president
of the country that was what I remember
and I was there and I was working there
at the time now I'm a business person
I'm not a politician and I like to look
at things like a CEO looks of things
and I have a board of directors and I
have shareholders and the companies I
own and they come to me and they say
annually they say we're gonna have a
report card for what you do it's called
an annual report and on that basis your
company shares trade or or how we pay
you as determined so let's have a little
bit of a report card on how mr. Putin
has done in terms of his running the
country from 1999 it starred as Prime
Minister and as president in 2000 well
I'd like to start with what Christopher
Granville said the poverty level in
Russia was 40% of the population World
Bank statistic lived at poverty levels
today it is 11% it is better than the
United States of America by 1% that is a
factual world bank statistic not made up
by me but by the World Bank so that's
what happened
that's what happened in the in the last
12 years since we've had mr. Putin and
all of those Russians have left poverty
and have gone into what we call the
middle class personal income in 1999 the
average Russian was making 42 the
equivalent of 40 to 50 dollars today on
an inflation-adjusted basis his there
pays up 2.6% 2.6 times sorry
2.6 times two four hundred to four
hundred and fifty dollars the standard
of living in a poll recently run 43
percent of Russians believe that the
standard of living of their families has
improved 20 percent believe it is
worsened unemployment in 1999 was at 15%
today it is at 5% inflation was it 30
per 36 percent today it is it 6.6
percent the middle class was at 11
percent in 99 today 48 percent would be
considered middle class the gross
domestic product has grown in that same
period by two times on an average of 5%
annually exceeding Brazil which grew up
1.5 percent during that period of time
India two point four percent at a time
China three and a half and the United
States the great United States at one
point two percent I'm an American by the
way gross domestic capital per per
capita gross domestic product per capita
is the highest of all the BRIC countries
and in 2012 reached 14,000 dollars
compared to Brazil's eleven point three
India's 1500
six thousand growth of ten times from
1330 in 1999 to where we are today
incredible statistics debt-to-gdp one of
Russia's biggest problems Marshall said
they used the Stabilization Fund to pay
down debt don't forget that in 1998
Russia was crushed by that debt that it
had and it had defaulted on the debt and
by the way it is the reason the g7 today
is collapsing economically because of
the masses amounts of debt the United
States running at over a hundred percent
of GDP now Russia went from a hundred
and ten percent to 12 percent today and
that excuse me is I think was exactly
the way you had to spend the money
foreign exchange reserves the so-called
money that were squandered are now at a
half a trillion dollars and when Marsha
said that the the Stabilization Fund was
used it was actually used for
stabilization during the 2008 crisis it
was used to stabilize the Russian ruble
so it didn't collapse and it didn't
cause the same kind of effect that we
had in 1991 when hyperinflation felt
says said in and Russia the Soviet Union
collapsed so it actually was used for
exactly what it was set out to be used
for tax reform there is in a country not
a country I go to that doesn't say we
would love to have the Russian tax
system Putin took a tax system which was
incomprehensible and he lowered that
your tax rate the individuals tax rate
at 13 percent flat tax and increased tax
receipts by fivefold because everyone
started to pay it was transparent and
understandable
he took the corporate tax rate from
thirty five thirty three percent which
is the same as the United States right
now and he dropped it down to twenty
percent today and increased tax receipts
he also then moved the tax burden away
from the individual and put it on the
natural resource sector
thereby freeing up people to save and to
invest in their economy banking reform
was enormous we were through banking
reform we created transparency
international accounting standards and
what did that do it created a huge boost
in confidence in the ruble today the
ruble is used by 90% the dollar
virtually is not in circulation in
Russia as a currency and its
internationally convertible nobody
thought that would ever happen today you
can go to a London kiosk and convert
your rubles to dollars your rubles to
pounds that could never have been done
or even thought of and night and went
before he came to power mortgages are up
to 9% I can keep going and going but I'd
like to cover one or two more things
that were said the whole issue of the
independent independent polling agencies
well let me tell you that there was an
article two days ago in The Guardian
that Marsha I think was referring to
that said that only the Levada Center is
independent and they polled it and the
reason they're independent that is they
claim that 26% of the population
supports Putin versus the other two that
claimed it was 52%
well actually the Guardian got it wrong
because it was 63% by livadas poll that
said even more than the other two that
said Putin's popularity was a level of
63% and 26% was actually the index the
difference between those in favor and
those who felt that it wasn't a letter
is going out to the Guardian today from
I understand one of the polling agents
isn't so used to correct them in that so
actually Levada the so-called
independent polling agency said that
pooches popper is a level of 63% unlike
the other ones at 52% and if we talk
about mr. hunter Kolski as as the
guardian of democracy I mean that's just
laughable I mean I know this guy he was
ruthless
there are 1012 body bags behind that
organization of people that were
disappeared because of the way they ran
their business and in most civilized
countries he'd be in jail for life and
in some uncivilized countries one that I
come from he'd be in an electric chair
thank you
thank you
thank you obviously I remind you there
will be time for contributions reactions
questions from all of you and I'm sure
there's lots there in what you've just
heard that you'll want to respond to
Borah short and close to the critique
let's put it that way of the Guardian
newspaper which could almost be a cue
for our fourth speaker who is the senior
international correspondent for The
Guardian newspaper and the first Western
journalist to be expelled from Moscow
since the Cold War he is the author of a
book called mafia state how one
journalist became an enemy of the brutal
new Russia the one journalist of that
title is Luke Harding well thank you
very much Jonathan it's been fascinating
sitting here listening to Boris and
Christopher painting a sort of portrait
of a Russia which I'm afraid I simply
don't recognize and perhaps I can just
talk about my own personal experiences
which I think kind of emblematic of of
where we're at
I arrived in Russia with my wife and two
other small children in January 2007 as
the guardians Moscow correspondent I
think I was the eighth since the
Bolshevik Revolution in 1917 going back
to to Malcolm migration before him
Arthur Ransome who was number one and
pretty quickly
I found myself sort of plunged into what
you can only describe as their kind of
very badly written spy novel I mean
think kind of Skyfall and and Daniel
Craig but much much worse than that with
kind of rubbish dialogue poor
characterization repetitive staging this
kind of thing and what what happened in
my case was the first four months were
pretty uneventful and then two of my
Guardian colleagues from from Boris's
favorite newspaper interviewed Boris
Berezovsky in in in London who the late
Boris Berezovsky as as we all know is a
kind of someone who was self promoting
self aggrandizing figure and he told
them that he was doing nothing less than
plotting a revolution against Vladimir
Putin
and so the garden in the way that kind
of newspapers sometimes do when they're
excited put the story on the front page
the next day April 2007 I am plotting
Russian Revolution says Berezovsky my
misfortune was that I was asked to get a
quote from Dmitry Peskov who was Putin's
press spokesman at the time which he
gave me and then I was the third byline
Luke Hardy and Moscow on front page and
and I'm really after that I would say
the kind of sky fell on my head in in in
the Putin's Russia which the others talk
about what happened in my case and this
has happened to many other human rights
activists opposition people journalists
Russian journalists in particular was
that I had for example I had physical
surveillance so I suddenly had
unpromising young men in in cheap
leather jackets and brown shoes who
would kind of follow me around whatever
I'd go to a cafe or a restaurant and
they would kind of if matter is me they
would sort of come and they would kind
of dump a bag I think containing some
kind of recording device next to me and
this was quite funny this was kind of
more Inspector Clouseau than KGB but
nonetheless it went on so that was
physical surveillance then there was
electronic surveillance which happens to
I think most journalists in Moscow
certainly Western journalists but it was
quite ridiculous so my my mobile phone
here was was was bugged someone hacked
into my email accounts and in our other
dingy office next to Belarus gas station
in in in Moscow that the landline was
bugged as well and the reason I knew
this was because whenever I said
something I would make a joke about
Putin or say the word Berezovsky or
Litvinenko or some kind of humorous
aside and then there will be
like this so then you carry on and then
you make another joke about Putin you
know and at first I thought I thought
you know this is automated software and
then gradually I concluded there was
someone sitting in a FSB listening
station somewhere on the outskirts of
Moscow with a copy of probably a Russian
tabloid their feet up their headphones
on like in the life of others that
wonderful film about Stasi and so tried
a small experiment instead of saying
Berezovsky I tried the word banana and
this worked amazingly I had a
conversation for five minutes
uninterrupted this I'd managed to outwit
you know by using this secret code so so
there was that and then another I think
emblem of this this dysfunctional Putin
state was that the FSB the successor
agency to the KGB which which Putin
headed until he became prime minister
and president in 1999 they broke into
their kind of family flat where I was
living with my wife and kids they they
didn't steal anything it wasn't like a
conventional burglary where someone
takes your TV and some money and jewelry
or whatever that they it was
demonstrative to show that they'd been
there so I came out with my small son to
discover that the locked window of his
bedroom we lived on the 10th floor and
there was a 20 meter drop to the
courtyard below which we always kept
locked was open with the kind of
symbolism that maybe he might just meet
with a little accident and fall out
there were alarm clocks that went off in
the middle of our night of the night
which we never found four o'clock 4:30 5
o'clock 5:30 I had a my family or on the
laptop a photo it was deleted one day I
came into my office and the phone was
off the hook
and and these kind of harassment
techniques are wheeled out by the
Kremlin against critics against people
seen as internal enemies and they there
was a humorous element to this too on
one occasion I came back to my flat and
discovered a strange book in Russian
about love and relationships and it had
been bookmarked the FSB had kindly boot
Martu for me and to page 110 so I turned
to page 110
and it's a page about orgasms and how to
have a better sex life when I'm sitting
that was one of the most surreal moments
of my life looking at this present from
the KGB FSB thinking you know am i doing
it wrong as it is it is it a technical
issue perhaps a frequency a frequency
thing and it was kind it was kind of
funny and we show this thing off at
dinner parties but on the same time it
wasn't funny because you know we had no
we had no private space for four years
and we discovered what we knew from the
bushi embassy at the time that suffered
similar break-ins it's done against
Western diplomats all the time and
others that there were there were bugs
audio-video in the bedroom the bathroom
kind of everywhere so so I entire
privacy was invaded
but by this thuggish organisation and
that was the private stuff additionally
we had the public stuff I was I got a
call one day from the FSB in in in
Moscow saying that they wanted to
interview me
and I said no I don't really want to be
interviewed they said you have no choice
so I reported about a week later with my
lawyer to LeFort over which is the kind
of notorious KGB jail in Moscow not
marked on any map but it does exist it's
a sort of pre Detention Center and I
turned up with my lawyer and we went
inside and there was a kind of waiting
room I'd say about half the size of this
stage but there were no kind of tables
and chairs there and said so there's
some psychological games for beginning
but there was an oblong kind of mirror
on the right-hand side demanding my
someone demanded my passport my mobile
phone all I saw of the spy on the other
side of the one-way mirror was a hand
and I noticed the hand was rather hairy
kind of hairy hands so the hairy hand
took my phone and then we proceeded
upstairs through this kind of each
elated corridor very much like the
service Tozzi headquarters to be
interrogated and one thing I remember is
in the the top of the ceiling there were
these old-style KGB cameras which sort
of followed us around as we trooped up
going
like this got to room 305 where a major
Kuzmin was waiting for us that was
almost certainly his nom de plume but
asking me about this kind of burns off
ski story and so on and so on and it was
a it was a pretty banal encounter but
the one thing I recall from it was that
on the table of his desk this is the FSB
major was a glass and on the glass were
four initials and those initials were
checkered OGG poo cargo bay EFS they in
and in other words basically the FS FS
babe that the FSB Putin's domestic
security organization sees itself
despite the end of the Cold War despite
the demise of communism as being in a
kind of direct line from the checker
Lenin's
you know first secret police performing
the same function which is to kind of
identify enemies of the state of whom I
think provisionally I was warned at that
stage and to smite them basically to
destroy them and just to wrap up my my
personal story this harassment went on
and off basically for about four years
then in the autumn of 2010 I was sitting
in our office reading is vesti a-- which
is a kind of rampantly pro-kremlin
newspaper but it had an interesting
article about someone called Julian
Assange the the the floppy had you know
founder of WikiLeaks who was promising
to open up a kind of box of secrets
about the post Soviet Union and so I
flew back to London and it turned out
that we we actually had all these
secrets about a quarter of a million
sort of diplomatic cables confidential
and secret diplomatic cables written by
US embassies and consulates around the
world and sent back to Washington and I
read them read these cables on Russia
and they were fascinating and I have to
say that they basically confirmed the
kind of stories that I'd been writing
for a long time certainly American
diplomats see see Russia very
differently from the way Boris sees it
and indeed from Christopher they they
talk about a mafia state they paint a
picture of of a kleptocracy of a
dysfunctional regime where organized
crime where the government
and where the FSB have kind of merged
into a kind of single a single entity
and I mean just to wrap up I just like
to say I mean you know Boris's
Statistics are lovely but I mean if if
if this is all true I wonder how he
explains why so many rich Russians come
and live in London buy property here
flee here when they kind of fall out and
I think there's an absolute lack of
faith really among Russians who support
the regime and Russians who oppose the
regime and what's going on at the moment
and well I think what is happening which
I serve our two opponents kind of skate
over is this political repression which
is really intensified I mean you can
make a case for early Putin perhaps up
to 2003 you can make a case for his
macroeconomic reforms for blowing the
tax rate for stabilizing Russian
finances but this is not because Putin
is some kind of fiscal magician is
because he's just historically he got
lucky he got lucky with the oil price
going up but what what we've seen the
middle Putin when I was there and I
would say the kind of Putin now is is
the kind of really I think a kind of
despot who who is retreating further and
further away from reality and is is
doing what Hillary Clinton described as
kind of reset ization in other words
bringing about the motifs of the Soviet
Union that the goons who used to come
into our flat I mean he's he's operating
from a playbook as if it were 1983
rather than kind of 2013 and really it's
a kind of it's dismaying what's
happening now and I'm afraid I do not
see Putin as Stanley Baldwin it's it's a
nice comparison oh do I see him as
Gordon Brown I mean I think that the
best that the best energy is Brezhnev
really what's happening in Russia now is
is frustration its its repression it's
it's emigration a lot of the best the
brightest Russians are leaving or being
forced to leave and I think it's a kind
of dismal picture and I don't think one
needs to be sophistical about this I
don't think one needs to be determinist
I think you used to need to use your
common sense and vote against this
motion thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you you've heard now from all four
of our speakers before you had had that
chance to hear from them you did vote as
you came in either for against for or
against the motion or as I don't know
let me give you the results of that
remember that was before you had been
swayed and swayed by the Ciceronian
rhetoric that has been unleashed from up
here but that the state of play before
them was those who were for the motion
those who agreed or believed that Putin
was good for Russia amounted to twenty
one percent of the room those who were
against who did not believe that Putin
has been good for Russia counted as
forty percent and the don't knows a very
large body of thirty nine percent
quarters of don't know thirty nine
percent so that is the group of people
who are up for grabs swing voters
floating voters have you'd like to
describe them so I say to the full
speakers up here those are the people
you have to win over this evening you've
done it perhaps already with your
opening speeches but now we're going to
open up and widen the debate so the way
I'd like to do it is to see some hands
go up and I'm going to take two or three
in a in a group there are people with
microphones let's get the microphone
here to the lady here and then you can
when you finish you can pass it just
straight along because there's another
person there and then we'll take the
gentleman there so we'll have a
microphone ready so we're going to start
with you I'm gonna do my generalized
plea here we've heard four very good
speeches we don't really want to hear
any more speeches what we want to hear
our short pointed questions and
contributions and I will make them short
and pointed if you don't do so already
mine is a question to voice and
Christopher what happens next one
remarkable thing about Putin is that
he's not laid out the future at all for
his country there's a complete lack of
institutions and you know it's not
exactly a meritocracy so if you think
he's been good for Russia how is he
building a good future for Russia thank
you and I'll make sure we hear an answer
to that and just parse it straight along
thank you hi thank you for your
contributions I you've all spoken a lot
about with domestic Putin and for me
there's a striking gap in this debate as
John Kerry recent
said gone are the days when you can
really separate between domestic and
foreign and I'd like to know what the
panel thinks about what Putin has done
for Russia's international standing as
well thank you
freeze international standing and all
our people questions as well for people
in the audience haven't completely heard
them clearly I'll be summarizing
repeating gentleman there well none of
speakers mentioned of course I miss
Prague the opposition didn't mention the
bombs in Moscow and vote Volga Danskin
September 1999 which killed 200 people
and I want to mention the steps of
course a two weeks later of course
Mississippi was some security service
where discovered is planting a bomb in a
apartment block in Ryazan
which has explained away as a training
exercise and then they said it was like
a bags of sugar or something in the if
they found the basement
so it's extreme the point is obviously
many people think that the bombs were
planted by the FSB and not spire
Chechens which is what the Russian
authorities said at the time and of
course the point is that Peter used this
excuse to send the troops into chechenya
okay don't you worry nope you don't have
to keep your hands up just now because
I'm going to get some responses and then
we'll take another round and we've got
we've got a good chunk of time so let's
hear from you first Christopher on that
very first question if Putin has been so
good what what future plans is he made I
don't think the question it means in
terms of succession strategy but in
terms of the future plan for the country
there is a succession strategy which is
obviously to replicate his ruling
establishment by repeating the operation
that was successfully done in much more
difficult circumstances in 1999 when the
embattled and discredited Yeltsin
administration having farcical II cast
around for various
successes at a very late stage alighted
on the unknown led the Amir blade you
nourish and as someone who could command
the support of the public and they were
right so I think that the plan is
probably to try to replicate that
operation but I think that's actually
your question was a deeper one and I
would make two comments first that the
unlike China where the political future
is so completely imponderable probably
the biggest question for our world today
in Russia the institutions are in place
the and like a vessel into which some
liquid has been poured more could easily
be poured you dont have choice-u to
invent anything there is the separation
of powers and as the political culture
matures the one institution which makes
sense to people in this culture which is
the elected president this is a pleb a
cycle a pleb a cycle a mild
authoritarian system will gradually
gradually improve it will gradually
mature and my second comment would be
this that putin continually says we need
to develop a political competition
without going off the rails without
going back into the abyss led there by
adventurers and dreamers and fanatics as
in 1917 now and then he also says we
must generate our own democracy from
within
that's his program now of course those
are self-serving arguments because they
kind of support his maintenance in power
but hey that doesn't mean to say they're
not true okay blue card in quick
response the separation of powers the
building blocks are in place for a
future democracy well it's nonsense and
I think Christopher knows as much
unfortunately
succession policy there is no succession
policy you know just look at Putin he's
just had his botox done he's flying with
cranes fly fishing this is not a man
who's about to relinquish the throne he
came back a year ago for a third
presidential term having basically
cheated by spending four years as Prime
Minister and having to meet you Medvedev
this is kind of seat-warmer he's now
back in his kind of world he's
indispensable he's on a kind of
historical mission and constitutionally
he can do another four years
and six more years after that and I
think he really sees himself going on
and on and on so there is no succession
strategy if a real successful to come in
they would immediately jail Putin and
his team and strip them of their assets
so the logic is he has to carry on and
in terms of institutions I mean this is
just kind of Andy Pandy
I mean you you have you have a sham
Parliament you have sham political
parties you have sham elections it's a
pretend world it's not a real world and
I think you know Russians see through
that and and separation of powers I mean
there's one executive power and that's
it I want to make sure other question
you're probably gonna want to come back
on that but I just want to put this
other second question we heard there
about the and we haven't done much on it
good for Russia internationally Putin
like him or hate him has some people say
restored Russia's clout on the world
stage he's a player that has to be
reckoned with muscle Britain has failed
in his 13 years in office to form a
coherent foreign policy his foreign
policy is created for domestic
consumption and it's very primitive it's
a policy of being scary respect and fear
are equal inputs his mind and to his
mind as long as Russia is feared on the
world stage
it is respected he's demonstrated that
very clearly and I think it's sort of
culminated with Syria and I think we're
watching the results of that policy you
might not like that but if it's feared
if the question before us is is it good
for Russia then we might not like that
but is being Russia being feared again
good for Russia I don't think that being
feared is good for Russia what is what
are tangible benefits that Russia gets
out of being feared it's just it's it's
it's it's symbolic capital of extremely
questionable nature but it certainly
brings no apparent benefit all right and
and finally to you Boris Jordan that
question they're very specific about the
evidence the allegation that some of
these incidents that occurred in the end
of the 20th century in Moscow were
perhaps put up jobs by the FSB and
obviously everyone knows Putin's own
background in
telogen s-- what do you say on that
claim that he actually engineered the
excuse to go into Church Enya and and
some of the larger points we've been
hearing about well I'd like to in terms
of order to start from the earlier ones
I think III want to just put everyone's
attention between the difference of our
arguments and our opponents arguments
our opponents come up with stories but
there's no facts it's all circumstantial
the fact is Russia has institutions for
reelection Russia's presidential
elections have been free and Putin did
win with a large majority I was
personally in one of the polling offices
that was doing the the early uh what are
they called early releases and I can
tell you that he was winning with a it's
he started out coming out from the
Siberian at a sixty five to seventy
percent level and then when it came to
Moscow he did drop dramatically in the
in the levels but he was well over fifty
percent on a polling basis and the the
fact is that Putin has consistently
since nineteen two from since 2001
pulled at an average of forty three
percent so I do think he's there is a
fair system and by the way obviously
Russia's democratic institutions are
young and I think we all need to
understand that in the scope of history
and this gets to the second point that
the mission Putin's global international
mission has been very similar to his
domestic mission and that is it was
economic it's purely economic and maybe
that's the shortcoming but his focus
everywhere has been economic and that is
to build up the the the the the economy
for the Russian Federation and to build
the foundation of a better life for
Russian citizens that's been his main
focus thank you lots and lots of hands
are up so I'm wondering try and get as
many as I can in let's hear from you up
here and then we'll bring it down to the
gentlemen here no no I know he didn't
respond to me because she knows
quadruped response just a question
because I'm not an expert on the subject
very I don't believe anyone in this room
is an expert you had to be there to no
measure very quickly on that and then I
really want to hear from people here
yeah well there's overwhelming evidence
that those explosions that
that brought Putin his incredible
popularity early on were organized by
the security services and one of the
pieces of evidences that was never
properly investigated were the facts I
have the facts conjecture very difficult
for her to present all that evidence in
this kind of format let's hear from you
yes hi
I'm not sure how serious or not serious
this point is but if you judge someone
from the friends that he has and I am
Italian living in London I think you see
where I'm going right
Putin is the best buddy of Berlusconi I
just okay I want to go to the I'm going
to come back to you I want to go to the
person who's got the microphone who's
here and did you have do you have it
with you what is the what is Putin's
personal and family wealth and what is
its source yep thank you my question is
why do you think everybody gives put in
such a hard time we look at Russia is a
emerging economy and enough NASA and
democracy and there's a few others
around the world
there's India there's China there's
places worse than that there's Pakistan
and yet if you read about these
countries in the press none of the
leaders of none of these countries is so
controversial as is Putin and sometimes
I wonder it's well it's really a kind of
reverse racism like the is there is the
racism you're imagining ants you Russian
or anti-putin in some way it's it's both
I guess
ok I feel slightly were being misled by
the question and maybe we're not
answering it correctly the question is
has
booting being good for Russia yeah not
whether we consider his despotic regime
to be something that we in the West
consider to be good nor the corruption
or anything else and I think we have to
confine ourselves to the question rather
than our views and you know loot stories
are all very amusing and also terrifying
but they don't actually relate to the
question good-o I did sort of make that
one from Russia earlier
thank you let's see what I'm doing this
by the way because I can't see you as
well as you can see all of us so that's
why I'm occasionally doing that it's not
some fear of incoming fire and let if
you've got the microphone ten minutes go
to UNIX and I'm gonna take two more and
bring it back here yeah it seems to me
where I understand from listening to all
of the panelists is that you can almost
definitely agree that economically
things have gone well but you can almost
certainly also surely agree that there's
being a price paid in terms of political
freedom is it worth that and what do we
see in terms of the future of Russia
with the the seeming destruction of
political freedom thank you
there was a woman here in here who I was
keen to include just to make sure we
have a balance of men and women and can
be parsed my compared to her there we go
yeah hi that's well we've heard a lot of
apples for apples arguments comparing
1990s Russia with early two-thousands
Russia I was just wondering if you think
it's fair to compare a country in the
early years of democracy straight out of
decades of a Soviet autocracy and on the
other hand a country which has had at
least 10 years of democracy building
institutions opening call it democracy
or not should thus the bar not be rather
higher for Putin thank you that's very
clear I've got this is going to be the
last one in this round don't worry I'm
still gonna try and get people in you've
been have your hand up for quite a long
time so is it gonna be the last one in
this round with luck and a fair wind we
should get some more in yeah good
evening I'm mr. Harding doubted that
Putin has democracy in mind but there
are
historical precedents for dictators
moving towards democracy
uncontroversially I could mention
Napoleon the third for example who in
1869 before the franco-prussian war
finished off his regime did introduce
the regime parramatta so surely there
are historical precedents for dictators
becoming Democrats this we've had
Stanley Baldwin we can have a Napoleon
3rd I'm open I'm open to all analogies
here Marcia you want to get in very
quickly just I wanted to make sure that
you do address the question there from
which said you've given us good answers
why we might not like Vladimir Putin in
his style but maybe he is good for
Russia and I'd like you to address that
well as a Russian I would like to say
that it is not pleasant
happy or most importantly hopeful to
live in a country where power is based
on fear ok it's concise but I want to
put you Christopher Granville this point
very very very specific question what is
estimate believes for as putin's wealth
and perhaps much more importantly what
is its source anyone who says they know
is bluffing it's all conjecture just as
anyone who says they know what happened
about the apartment block bombings in
1999 is bluffing we could go on like
this forever it is futile the other
reason for the second chechen Chechnya
war by the way in 1999 was an invasion
of Dagestan by jihadi forces on the
shamil Basayev which one I had jihadism
rooted in the North Caucasus because
unfortunately Boris Yeltsin took the
disastrous decision to go for a military
solution in Chechnya in December 1994
that's the reason so don't know is the
answer and the but if you want my
opinion I'll lay my cards out now I
regard myself not as a rosy eyed naive
Lenin called useful idiot but as a
boring middle-of-the-road man on the
spectrum of the natural resource curse
there is the Democratic Congo the
Republic of Congo at one extreme
everything is looted for the benefit of
the rulers the other extreme is Norway
where these resources are husband
for the benefit of countless future
generations of Norwegians Russia is
boringly in the middle of this spectrum
it shows undoubted symptoms of the
natural resource curse but also a ruling
establishment that for all its false is
has a sense of the country a sense of
ambition and pride and trying to move
things forward according to their lights
which from our sophisticated comfortable
complacent Blair rights point of view is
perhaps leaves a lot to be desired but
does offer a path forward and that is
the basis not namby-pamby as Lula saying
that is the realistic basis for
supposing in favor of this motion I'm
going to take your reference to Tony
Blair as an answer to the question about
Berlusconi so will will will now
consider that address no I I want to get
Luke Harding now in because you wanted
to get in on that but I think you should
also address this question that your
personal story very affecting it was to
to hear it but in a way bad for you is
it necessarily bad for Russia yeah I
mean on the money I mean Christopher's
right and surprise we don't know in 2007
I did a story based on sources inside
Putin's own presidential administration
which who was saying that he was worth
about 40 billion dollars held basically
through a series of proxies in oil and
gas companies in Russia and I did you
know but before writing this story
before we published his story I did what
you would do which is I talk to
transparency international I talk to
other sources and then with some
trepidation I phoned up the Kremlin and
tried to ask them how much is Putin
worth I found 16 times I sent 20 emails
there was no reply even no one actually
wanted to talk about the story for kind
of three months afterwards when Putin
kind of finally sort of denied it but
the fact is that actually I don't see it
as Christopher's curve I mean this is
one of the greatest corruption stories
in human history not because Russia has
discovered corruption because the
volumes are so great in terms of Russia
being the biggest exporter of oil and
gas Putin and his team worth billions
and billions and billions of dollars
and they're not sort of self-interested
so they're not self as custodians of of
the Russian national interests they are
kleptocrats who have enriched themselves
massively and as far as my stories go
well that's your view I mean the reason
I think it's worth sharing them with you
is because I think it speaks to
something more profound which is that I
think Putin's biggest failure in a way
is intellectual he hasn't come up with a
new national idea I mean he's still
using the old KGB handbook he's wheeling
out taxes which we use at the height of
the Cold War during the Brezhnev and
drop off eras and I think this is the
problem this is why Christopher
struggles to answer the question as to
where Russia is going because there is
no vision at the moment it's going in to
a dead end
I know that you Boris children want to
come back on that I also want to hear
what your answer is to the question of
why you think people do give Putin such
a hard time if he said as great as the
picture you painted before and perhaps
but you also want to address his other
one well regarding that there was a
great question about whether the the
economic success of what he's done was
worth it in terms of the politics and
I'd like to say you know there's a great
reference I was recently both read but
also saw the recent great picture about
a great American Democrat probably
revered more than any President Lincoln
and I'd like to ask the question the
audience the question was it worth that
Lincoln bought the vote to free the
slaves was it worth it I think it was so
what he bought the vote the point on
that point being that we are in a young
democracy the one to which foundations
are being built I thought another
question by a young lady in the back
this democracy is literally you know 15
years old it is what's most important
after a thousand years of
totalitarianism and my family suffered
in that totalitarianism tremendously
under the Communists who butchered and
slaughtered my family I can tell you
that after that thousand years of
totalitarian rule coming out the first
thing the average Russian really cares
about is his security and his ability to
create a life for his
and that was the issue that everyone
worried about in night from 1992 to 1999
as the country was falling apart and
going into hyperinflation defaulting on
its debt today that isn't the case as a
matter of fact a recent very interesting
poll was would you go out in Moscow of a
thousand respondents were which we did
it through one of the agencies one
through the one of the independent
agencies was would you go out to to a
demonstration against Putin today and 2%
said yes then we said would you go out
for demonstration for Putin and 2% said
yes people don't really care about that
today
what they care about is building their
economic well-being okay though I know
there were questions you asked that we
haven't yet managed to get to we're
really short on time what I'm going to
do is take an absolute Whistlestop round
now and then we're going to hear closing
remarks from people here so you
gentlemen there if we can bring the
microphone to the lady there and then
there people there's somebody upstairs
and I'll take one from over there so
sorry we haven't got more time yeah
wherever you are yes
thanks very much there are suggestions
now I don't think anyone's really
suggesting things are as bad as they
were in the Soviet Union when I lived
there is a student and later work there
is a journalist but it's a bit baffling
to me to hear the suggestion that is
either freer than ever which was one
suggestion or there's no information on
the problems of the their business need
to hear from those who are in favor of
the motion that Putin has been good for
Russia what your view is on in that case
the number of new laws to been
introduced having a very serious effect
on non-governmental organizations civil
society more generally
Human Rights Watch Amnesty International
Russian organizations and specifically
garlis the voice working on independent
monitoring elections they are being
pressured they're being fine then don't
use we've got we got the point thank you
very much yes indeed yeah I want to just
say that um mr. Harding said that a
diplomats wouldn't recognize the Russia
described by or Stern but I was a US
diplomat there throughout the 90s up to
2003 and I agree with everything every
point he made and X I would add one
point that the branches every point you
made so you go toward you agree with
this the only point I would
even the branches of government we're
fighting each other right the white
house getting bombed by the executive
Bret um that would be one quit just to
set the record but I wanted to say that
of course now there are terrible pumps
with with press and the programs I
administered in the embassy are now
being sort of shut down and inhibited
but I still think we can and I'm glad we
have the pre-op picture of Putin because
I think his yeah Botox days are worse
for Russia and I but I still think we
can say yes to the proposition because
he has been good it was a period he was
an essential guy maybe Thomas Jefferson
would be better but he was damn good
thank you
okay the algorithm is necessary for
where the country was and I said I would
take two oh we've got somebody up here
all right
yeah and then we can take one from over
there yeah so Boris used the argument
that Russia has only twenty years of
democracy after the Soviet era and
therefore a lot can be forgiven
why are countries like Estonia with
exactly the same duration of democracy
are doing so much better in the sort of
public liberty sense thank you point of
comparison this is going to have to be
the last song I'm so sorry
and I'm going to go to the not not there
but the person who's in the front of
this block just behind this one yeah
yeah thank you sorry to others or I
didn't have time for yeah I'd like a
remark for but it's your than it really
be a question
said a very laughable speech about
democracy in Russia if it was so sad
and about democracy you could tell for
the families of political prisoners in
Russia who are sitting now in prisons
and everybody knows this there is no
independent court in Russia there is no
independent mass media people persecuted
by their political views I escaped from
Russia and was granted political asylum
because I didn't want to sit in a prison
for my political views and tell about
democracy all the people who are
fighting for the freedoms and rights in
Russia thank you I'm so sorry - thank
you
apologies again to those of you wanted
to get in but there we are outstanding
fact we started running either now is
the point where I'm going to ask you to
vote on what you've heard and while
you're doing that people are tell us
we'll be coming round with the ballot
boxes remember the form you have the
formula says yes no and there it is for
and against it says so if you are for
the motion you believe that Putin has
been good for Russia tear off the black
portion there with the word for and put
it in the ballot box and if you are
against put in the motion say the word
against and if you Shh because we're
still gonna hear for more we're gonna
hear respond from our panel if you're
against put in the little white slip
that says against and if you still don't
know or you want to abstain put the
whole thing inside while you're doing
that and I would urge you to be as quiet
as you can because we're going to give a
final chance to our panel to sway you if
you haven't yet voted with closing
arguments and if you can address as you
do so panel some of the points you heard
there about the the argument the country
isn't freer than ever the attacks on
NGOs the gentleman who said he escaped
from Russia all perhaps alternative of
the US diplomat who said she was there
in the 90s and she absolutely recognized
the transformation of the Putin was
necessary if you can address those two
that would be good closing argument from
you you have two two to three minutes
first off Luke Harding and quite please
if we can for these closing remarks well
thank you I'll just pick up on a couple
of quick points the u.s. to come out I
think you're talking about early Putin
rather than late person I wonder if
might befall the current US ambassador
who's been hounded persecuted harassed
intimidated would would agree with that
that Putin has been so good all or
perhaps the US diplomat recently caught
with a wig in what was clearly a kind of
rather ridiculous sort of setup American
diplomats have been on the receiving end
of a lot of nastiness I would say from
about 2006 almost after you left just to
close political prisoners there's some
people we didn't mention today Anna
Politkovskaya shot dead in 2006 and the
stairwell of her apartment Natalia esta
mujer OVA abducted in Grozny from where
she was working for the human rights
organization memorial and murdered by
the side of the road Mikhail back at of
a local journalist in Kim ki who wrote
about corruption tried to preserve the
forests there and who was savagely
beaten and died two months ago the list
goes on and on you know brave reporters
these Russians human rights workers
journalists campaigners often not in
Moscow st. Petersburg but in the
provinces these are the people have been
good for Russia not the kleptocrats not
the people who've made money from Russia
a large amounts of money but people
who've stood up for what they believe in
who've kept alive the kind of the kind
of moral self if you like in in
increasingly difficult circumstances and
I have an idea perhaps a quick quixotic
idea maybe maybe a ridiculous idea that
at some points maybe as an old man or my
Zimmer frame I will be able to go back
to a genuinely democratic Russia even
semi democratic would be fine and walk
down the street named after s Timur ever
named after Politkovskaya named off
after Paquette often III vote for you to
oppose that motion then perhaps make
this dream a little bit closer to
reality thank you your list there I
wonder where you place holder coughs key
who we heard attacked by Boris Jordan
who said you know in any other country
he should be in jail you know forever
and other people do list him as a sort
of political prisoner where do you stand
on that I mean I I think I think you
know he's he's a tricky figure but I
also think he's essentially kind of
redeemed himself in jail and I just like
to say he may well have stirred in large
amounts of money in the 1990s but that's
not why he's in prison he's in prison
for disrespecting Vladimir Putin who's a
very touchy guy and you know if anyone
if everyone who'd stole money in the
1990s were in prison then the entire
oligarchic class would be in jail not
just cut across ski all right thank you
for he's closing remarks we turn now to
Boris Jordan you've heard all the
arguments made one particularly address
which you that first question in that
last round about the attacks on
nongovernmental organizations NGOs the
questioner listed them by way of
rebutting your argument that Russia was
freer than ever well I think firstly I'd
like to say that it is obvious and I
said it before that um Russia's a very
early stage of its democratic roots and
its development and again I want to
reiterate for those that are history
buffs as I am on Russian history we have
come out of 1,000 years of totalitarian
rule and I can tell you the Russia we
have today is so much better than
anything that we had in the last
certainly the last eighty years under
communist rule and certainly better than
what we had in the 1990s and the Russian
people vote that way every single four
years and there has been no one that has
been able to come up and to argue the
point against mainly because there isn't
enough support for anyone because people
live well and as we say in the United
States people vote their pockets and in
that regard
Putin has done a very good job of making
sure that the population has done better
annually every year now regarding the
issues of that were brought up first of
all the issue on Estonia as I understand
let's be honest Russians don't limit
anybody from voting the Estonians don't
let Russians vote so let's not talk
about countries that are free or not
free Russia in that regard right so and
have have regularly and constantly held
back the ability to get citizenship and
virtually disallow any citizenship in
their country of Russian citizens that's
a massive repression as far as I'm
concerned and that is a country that's
supposedly applying or it already is in
the EU so I'd like to say that in in in
in closing arguments that there's no
question a lot of work needs to be done
but the question that was put today to
all of you Wes has been Putin been good
for Russia and my argument is that up
until today and we will see how it goes
forward he has been good for Russia and
the Russians who are more relevant than
all of us here are the people that have
been voting YES on that issue cited that
Pope recited that hold earlier when you
ask people when people were asked you
know would you go out and protest
against Putin how confident are you that
the figures there don't aren't partly
influenced by fear of saying yes I would
like to go and protest against PT no I
listen today you know we had in May we
had a demonstration that was you know 20
some 1,000 people came out the fact is
today whether that's good or bad
but the fact is the opposition to Putin
rule today is less than 20% of any kind
of dissent and mostly it comes out of
Moscow and st. Petersburg the rest of
the country is hugely supportive of what
Putin has done and that comes through in
every single poll including the poll
that was misquoted by the Guardian it
wasn't 26% that support which and it was
actually 63% that support Putin and that
comes of course whether you're an
independent or a so-called and not
independent polling that comes across in
every single poll what I'm saying is how
comforting can you be that people are
honest to post as well what they really
feel is they're not a climate of the
pollster and of course let me tell you
the pollster that I largely depend on
this an individual who has been doing
this for 20 years and he's the one that
actually came up with one of the first
polls in 1986 that said that Yeltsin was
running at a 3% success ratio and it's
form and Alexandra Sloan is an
incredibly independent
Ulster everyone who knows him he's an
academic and knows that that's the way
he functions and he does a lot of work
for our company for other companies he
does a good job Thank You Masha Gessen
you keep your closing remarks and one of
the questions I would like you to
address it was the former US diplomat
there who said you know it was you it
was awful 20 years ago branches of
government fighting each other he may
not be Thomas Jefferson but he's been
necessary for Russia
well actually what I would like to say
is first of all that there the
distinction between the early person and
late Putin is a completely false
distinction Putin on his first day in
office the two things happened this is
his first day after he was inaugurated
he proposed a legislative package that
laid out the blueprint for dismantling
the Russian electoral system and he
followed through on that blueprint quite
consistently completing the process of
dismantling the electoral system by 2004
when gubernatorial elections were
eliminated and direct elections to the
Duma were eliminated the other thing
that happened on his first day in office
was the raid on the offices of media
most the largest independent media
company in Russia which then Boris
Jordan was used to to run on behalf of
the state company Gazprom now where
Jordan has accused me of not using facts
well I will like to accuse him of
misrepresenting facts one of the
misrepresentations that you've heard is
that Russia is in the early stages of
democracy that makes it sound as though
Russia has been on a smooth or at least
a consistent trajectory for the last 20
years well that is a key distinction
Russia was an eternal one trajectory
until 2001 Putin came to power and has
been a completely different trajectory
for the last 13 years the process of
dismantling what democracy there was in
the 90s has intensified in the last year
and that's how responding to the
question over there that's how we know
that Putin doesn't have democracy in
mind because we look at the trend we
look at the direction in which he is
taking Russia the laws that have been
passed in the last year which severe
really restrict the freedom to gather
publicly and that accounts enlarge a
part of course for why people are not
willing to come out to protest aside
from feeling that that's completely
hopeless but the law the new laws have
made it possible to prosecute anybody
for anything related to public
gatherings they have also instituted
back-breaking fines up to nearly a
thousand dollars for an individual for
violating random laws and public
gatherings the laws on so-called foreign
agents which are geared at eliminating
civil society in Russia and Mike my word
by the end of this year there will be no
civil society organizations left in
Russia the new laws that make it
possible to prosecute virtually anybody
for espionage or high treason and
finally one more thing the 63 percent
figure that figure
that came from the Nevada Center which
is an independent polling organization
is not a popularity figure the 63
percent was a very accurate prediction
of the voting results now Levada has
been very clear on this
that they do not release raw numbers
they release the raw numbers corrected
by the coefficient to predict the
results that the regime will claim to
have received in voting which is exactly
what happened they claimed to get 63%
all right and we gave him the first word
he's also going to get the last word to
sum up Christopher Granville and what
are the question I'd like to you to
address if you could was the gentlemen
they said told us he had escaped from
Russia in order to escape jail for his
political beliefs he said when you had
said earlier that the country is freer
than ever before he said tell that to
the families of the political prisoners
I'd like you to address thank you
Jonathan with pleasure and with your
permission I'd link that question - I
thought the spots on question which came
from the front row the gentleman sitting
just down there on the has the price
that has been paid for the recovery of
living standards and the reduction of
poverty
a sense of stability and confidence in
the future
has that been too high now it's always
nice to think that one doesn't have to
pay such a high price that one could
have got the desirable thing for Less
it's a nice thought to have it's nice to
vote against this motion perhaps on
those grounds but ask yourself honestly
ladies and gentlemen is it realistic
when I said that Russia was freer than
before I'm thinking of the 1990s the
re-election of Boris Yeltsin in 1996 was
certainly rigged the country was run by
oligarchs there was the press was not
free we haven't got less free there was
unbelievable plunder so for all the
ugliness we see today has it got worse
than 1990s it was an excellent excellent
question for me I thought up from the
balcony there about Estonia I'm you
heard I'm keen on counterfactuals so if
her stoner is okay why not Russia bad
example I'm afraid Estonia only had a
one generation under Soviet Communism
before that it was a free country here's
a counterfactual for you
Ukraine ah looks more democratic doesn't
it but not even back to its Soviet lever
the standard of living hugely inferior
demographic and health indicators
despite its democracy so there I think
gives you food for thought about what is
really possible what price is acceptable
and on the last point about NGOs well
what Massa just said is is rubbish and
it's an insult
there will be no NGOs left in Russia
there's a huge and growing civil society
movements of charitable organizations
which are very active in protesting
against authorities in all sorts of ways
go loss was mentioned this is an NGO
which looks at fair voting now there is
this rule that if you take foreign money
as an NGO to be a politically active NGO
domestically you have to register
yourself as a foreign agent you don't
get closed down you wanna get closed
down if you don't obey the law now of
course this is a little bit paranoid but
Russia has to sort out its own [ __ ]
forgive me
it has to develop its democracy from
within if it's grafted on by the OSCE
the National Democratic foundation its
Council of Europe god knows what it will
be rejected even if democracy hadn't
been discredited the 1990s by being
associated with loot rapine and
oligarchy so really has it it's been
good for Russia is there a way forward
out of this unlike the Soviet Union
there most certainly is and that is why
I'm sure you have supported this motion
it is too late for me to change our
minds thank you thank you thank you very
much since the subject of the next
intelligence squared event is to be
Neville Chamberlain I'm glad to be able
to tell you I have here a piece of paper
in my hand and let's just tell you now
the debate results before you came in
before you had a chance to these
sterling and sparkling arguments 21% of
you agreed with the motion that Putin
has been good for Russia 40% of you
disagreed and 39% would don't knows I
can now tell you that having debated the
motion 37% are for the motion that Putin
has been good for Russia so a big
increase from 21 to 37% but now against
the motion
was 40% before now 57% of you believe
that Putin has not figured for Russia
and only 6% of you would don't know so
an almost Putin s victory margin of 57%
for our people against the motion it
only remains for me to wish obviously a
good evening but to thank our sterling
speakers up here
Christopher Granville Boris Jordan
mutter guessin and Luc Harden
thanks very much